how do you find a suitable research
topic how can you formulate your
research problem precisely and what do
you have to pay attention to so that you
don't get stuck in the end we'll go over
that in this video
at the beginning of your thesis you
first have to find a suitable topic
important take your time to choose a
topic and do some rough research
otherwise you can make your life
unnecessarily difficult to start we need
to put a few terms in order in the
literature and depending on your
supervisor different terms are used when
it comes to the research topic most
often you hear the terms research topic
or subject research problem and central
question
a common approach is that the research
topic very broadly outlines the topic
the research topic is then defined in
more detail with the help of the
research problem so the research problem
is the specified research topic if you
then formulate your research problem in
question form you will get the central
question of your thesis so both are more
or less the same only ones defined as a
statement and once as a question before
we discuss how to get to the heart of
your research problem you need to find a
suitable research topic how do you find
a suitable research topic the most
common ways to find a subject for your
thesis are first you take a topic given
by your supervisor or second you choose
a topic yourself I'm going to give you
some tips on how to find a topic
yourself for first write down as many
topic ideas as you can try not to judge
your ideas just write down everything
that comes to your mind next select the
topic from your brainstorming list that
catches your eye first
take a blank sheet of paper and some
pens write the topic or Central Concept
in the center of the sheet right around
it those terms that come to your mind
about the topic and finally draw lines
between the terms to show the
connections what is an easy way to find
a research topic an easy way to get a
topic for your empirical thesis is to
see if you can find the study that you
can modify or replicate an example a
study used population X did experiment
that and presented the results in a
certain way now you simply choose a
different population and do everything
else the same the advantage is you can
stick to the research design and the
methods used in the existing study you
then have a guideline from the beginning
that you can follow
important there are different
requirements depending on the type of
scientific work for a master's thesis or
a dissertation you should find your own
research Gap in the literature and
address it on your own for this you can
ask yourself the following question what
is the added value of your topic to the
literature think about how your research
can address a topic that has not been
studied before to come up with topics
that have not been explored yet the
following list can help you
investigation of an unusual place for
example Rural America investigating an
unusual group of participants taking a
perspective that may not be expected and
reversing the expectation for example
why marriages work rather than why they
don't
providing novel means of collecting data
for example capturing sounds
presenting results in unusual ways for
example charts showing Geographic
locations investigating a current issue
for example the high inflation
but how do you get from the research
topic to the specific research problem
to get to the heart of your topic you
can try to Define your work more
precisely with the following questions
thus the subject need to be restricted
locally thus the topic need to be
limited in time which contents or terms
of the topic can be specified and
defined more precisely does your topic
indicate the method used or the data
being studied and thus the topic
indicate the goal of your work let's
walk through this with an example let's
assume your research topic is initially
the political discourse in the media now
let's go through the Five Points first
thus the subject need to be restricted
locally the political discourse in the
media we will certainly not look at the
whole world let's say you're interested
in the U.S media
number two does the topic need to be
limited in time the political discourse
in the U.S media but what time let's say
you're interested in the political
discourse in 2020
number three which contents or terms of
the topic can be specified and defined
more precisely political discourse in
the U.S media in 2020 which political
discourse and which U.S media you're
interested in the political discourse on
the Corona pandemic in the U.S
newspapers The Wall Street Journal the
New York Times and USA Today
thus your topic indicate the method used
or the data being studied
well at least we know that the data
comes from the daily newspapers Wall
Street Journal New York Times and USA
Today in 2020 and the last Point number
five thus the topic indicate the goal of
your work your goal is a media critical
comparison this brings us from the broad
topic the political discourse in the
media to the much more specified
research problem the political discourse
on the Corona pandemic in the U.S
newspapers The Wall Street Journal the
New York Times and USA Today in the year
2020 a media critical comparison
with this you have mastered the
transition from the research topic to
the more specific research problem you
have now defined exactly what you want
to study in your thesis
but what about the central research
question the central question is the
overarching question you want to answer
in your thesis
simply put the central question is the
research problem in question form let's
go back to our example with the
political discourse
our specified topic or research problem
here is
to get to your central question you can
now simply
reformulate your research problem into a
question here it is useful to use other
words or synonyms your central question
could therefore be how is the debate on
the Corona pandemic at the political
level in 2020 presented in the U.S
newspapers The Wall Street Journal the
New York Times and USA Today
as shown in this video finding a
research topic and literature review is
an iterative process it is also possible
that you simply start in the literature
research with a certain keyword and then
find your way to a suitable topic with
the help of the literature
note the later you do a literature
research the more difficult you make
your life so it's best to start with a
first literature research as early as
possible and now we continue with the
video on literature research we will
discuss how to approach a systematic
literature research how to prepare the
current state of research how to develop
the theoretical background and finally
how to derive research questions and
hypotheses
thanks for watching and I hope to see
you in the next video